hey i'm private hornsby 942-326-1
refrigerator tech hi kelly kelly
so i haven't been using any of those
dating apps i haven't been on any dates
lately
i've been voluntarily celibate just
enjoying my own company voluntary
selling god bless you i like that term i
like you you're just just knowing
what you're doing thank you thank you
very much i should just go on an
innocent little date tonight what's the
worst thing that can happen my dumb ass
invited somebody
to my sanctuary otherwise known as italy
for tiramisu okay this is one thing i
will say
you got a spot you really like going to
and uh you're going on the first date
and you invite the [ __ ] over and
they start coming even after you stop
seeing them oh it's like when you bring
um
but your girlfriend to your favorite
spot like it's like a thursday night
and she starts showing up when you not
together yeah changing
dynamics what she mean by sanctuary she
means
like her spot i was a favorite spot so i
was swiping away on bumble
left right left right and i swiped up
somebody who was super attractive
like i mean he looked like aladdin
prince ali
aliyama i guess you know that was not a
brand
a whole new world i mean
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] if i want to go a
whole new world i go
up i'll go about it no no no no no
alibaba's a good song a whole new world
is a good song as well
if you were simp what
yeah yeah it's a sip song no it's not
can i say song no it's not
sing it i won't yeah exactly because you
don't want to sound simple
not at all i'm like ah insecurity he's
so
cute he's not gonna swipe right on me
because he looks like
a beautiful prince
[ __ ] i'm gonna give you that one yeah
yeah yeah yeah psychic
i'm gonna give you that one and you
already saw the video but let me give
you that one i didn't watch this whole
video
hold on no no are you saying that i
watched the video and then i
pre-registered and i'm like let me do
this yeah that's what i
think okay i see how you are because ali
who's ally a mother
that's what you are [ __ ]
just give me my credit i predict that
yeah you pretty much
[ __ ] i kissed him you was right right
let's go [ __ ] he swiped right i'm like
oh my god
i texted him hi how's your sunday going
he sent a paragraph back like
i'm having a great evening how about you
i'm like oh he actually messages
paragraphs that's like me because i
always send essays to people
anyway he's a really good texter so far
and i don't like texting i said hey you
know you want to ask me all these
questions why don't we just
talk about this in person i'm going to
get tiramisu right now hey man i like
this girl she said yo man cut the chit
chat [ __ ] you trying to get some
i'm trying to get some like we meeting
or not you know what i like the way
she just moved it straight to the date
after the parties they have to party you
know i'm saying after the half the party
is the hotel lobby
all right kelly stop it i'm going to get
tiramisu
would you like to meet me i go to italy
it's my favorite spot he's like okay
i'll be there in 15 minutes i'm like all
right
so i'm pulling up i'm looking inside to
see just in case is he like a 90 year
old
man because sometimes i get catfished i
look in i see
aladdin um he's standing there
and he's looking fine so i'm like oh
he's tall
he has his like hair going i look at the
cheekbone
it's very rare that i get to meet a girl
creepier than me
i'm like damn i walk into italy
and he's like hey kelly i'm like oh
i was expecting him to have like a
badass
peaky blenders like gangster accent
like i am going to impregnate you
hey i'm going to impregnate
documentaries i'm he's like wow this
place is really
really cool i've never been here before
he's like is that the tiramisu like
why are they selling bill cosby well the
name of the capital that you had fun
with
where you were in the army the capital
oh oh you mean
one foreign tech hi kelly
kelly would you like to go on a date
today i'm so excited
huh and you walk like this
every time we would march this [ __ ] was
a
was a walking meme bro god bless him
and he's like should we get one or two
i'm like we should get one each
cause i don't like to share it's my kind
of girl but there's one thing i hate
is when a girl is like we're just gonna
share i'm not even that hungry
you're gonna be hungry in five minutes
you know what i hate i hate this want
something nah i'm good
you want something no i'm good
oh this looks good no girl no no
no no no there's a restaurant in the
states
where you order the name of is not that
hungry
it's an another order of fries another
fruit
that's just genius that's actually smart
i'm gonna say this i blew up a date one
time
because of this issue i went to the
desert spot right i took her to a nice
dessert spot in the city
so we're talking he's like tell me all
about you i'm like
hey people ask me that like ask me what
are my interests he's like so what do
you do for work
i hate people ask that like let's just
talk about your interests let's go eat
some good food let's
i wonder what music you listen to he
doesn't know that
because he doesn't know you but i get
what you're saying
flip side most people don't like their
work or are passionate about their work
fair odds are you're going to be way
more passionate or interested in the
music that you listen to
than the work i agree so love you i have
to remind kelly i'm not in the dating
world
and he said something along the lines of
like
i'm not trying to stalk you i watch svu
and i'm like
oh you know i like my svu this is good
this is going somewhere
quick side note as view is trash the
only law in order that's good is the
original one yeah
svu literally betrayed the whole series
because it did the one thing that you're
not supposed to do with law order get
into the personal lives of the
detectives like nobody cares
law and order was always about the case
and its implications
his view comes along it's like well i'm
olivia's mom and
are we dating i was like what is this
drama this is like traditional cop drum
which i hate so i'm getting invested now
like his voice is getting less annoying
he's really intrigued by me and he loves
svu i'm like this is good
and then he goes oh there's just one
more thing oh my god so i have to tell
you
i really like you i like your energy
you're very assertive and you sound like
you're outgoing and you're ambitious
i do have to tell you something like do
you have hiv
he goes no like are you married no
no god no it's nothing like that i'm
like oh what is it he goes
i do have a kid my heart kind of sunk
i'm like oh there it is
there it is he goes does that bother you
if i knew that he had a child i would
not have met
your profile says you don't want kids
he's not asking you to be pregnant like
there's a lot of interpretation
it doesn't mean that you don't like kids
no no if you say you don't want kids
that generally means you're not
interested in somebody who has kids
generally
i don't know about that and also also
and if you're unsure ambiguous if you're
going on a date just tell the person
beforehand
so they can make that decision sure and
also if you got a profile and you're
like
oh i'm six two i work in private equity
by the way i'm dark tall dark and
handsome but you don't mention the fact
that you have kids
that's a problem i understand what
you're saying i mean at the end of the
day you're you're a dating specialist
the problem is he provided so much
information that would work in his favor
but one big thing that most people are
concerned with he didn't it's like
not mentioning in your profile that
you're married i understand not
mentioning the profile that you have
you should tell people i am 23 i don't
want to deal with your baby mama drama
don't want it it depends like like how
what's your relationship like with your
child and your ex-wife he goes we didn't
end things amicably
um i give her a lot of money every month
yeah i know you kind of have to tell
that especially
if your past is in the present it's
deception by a mission
yeah yeah you can't you can't admit that
kind of stuff yeah
like i don't want to be out of place and
a little kid comes up like
hi mommy i i
and as he's just talking about this i'm
just thinking about his bumble profile
and how none of this was on there
now a lot of men disclose on their
profiles
have children or don't want most people
do
put they have children they are honest
did he lie
by not disclosing that he had kids he
put all of the other filters but he
skipped that one
he's practically guilt-tripping me
saying you're such an amazing girl like
i've never had such a good date before
you have such great personality and i
don't want to pressure you like i fully
understand
if you don't want to be with somebody
who has kids i
i'm like wait kids you said kid he goes
all right i have three children wow
yeah girl yeah girl
yeah that's it you're done yeah we're
done
i'm sorry kelly i'm sorry about that
kelly kelly
wow that's swag kelly that is hella wack
he know what he was doing i really
apologize i apologize saying yeah you
just said that you didn't
no that that was not it that was clearly
not it i mean yeah i guess this just
comes back to what i said before it's
like it's not just a men thing like even
a lot of women who i've talked to
they hear the person and they're just
not into that idea it goes on both sides
of the aisle
absolutely you know wow kelly yeah i'm
sorry about that it's whacked
she was coming out of being um
voluntarily celibate and then she comes
out to this
you know i mean if it looks too good to
be true probably yes
yup you know um there's normally a
drawback with people who are
that level of attractive and that
available and that like into you right
away it's like
what's wrong considering this and you
have a pick of the litter why are you
here with me
i'd be super suspicious i've had that
happen before where they're super hot
like model type girl hit me up and i'm
like
i haven't even put any game in and
you're like who's here who sent you
you're
no no you're just eager like it didn't
make sense like
for how much work i put in what you were
giving me considering how you look and
how well i'm like who sent you and what
is that but i was like okay
and i just paid attention and then she
made her move very very smart
she's like so do you want to meet up and
here's what i said
if i've been talking to you for five
minutes and you will just push to meet
up yeah
i'm suspicious why do you think i'm
suspicious because you're too eager
that's not the game you're a woman yeah
how are you this trusted with someone
you've never met
really to meet in person yeah and go do
the dirty well we just i'm not had
big red flashes i'm like you know what
is this are you a dude like
what's going on are you trying to trying
to play me you think i'm gonna send you
nudes like what's happening right now
it's like no no i'm like all right so
what's what's the play
he's like what do you mean to play i'm
like there's something wrong right now
it's like no there isn't i'm like stop
fronting with me and she's like okay
are you willing to pay i was like there
you go there it was
there he was and i was just like and my
hat started chuckling i was like
no i'm not willing to pay and she says
oh that sucks and i'm like
but if you want to tell me about your
experiences you know i mean releasing
other [ __ ]
i'll definitely hear about your
experiences but i will never meet you so
always be a little bit suspicious when
people are that eager and they're that
attractive
but on the flip side he should have been
more forthcoming just be honest guys
whatever you got doesn't matter whether
it's kids or this or that like
just tell the people if you think it's
going to be a deal breaker rather be
upfront with it
weed out the people who are not open to
that and just get the people who
want to be with you you know what i mean
that's my take on it
so that's it for today's video let us
know what you guys think in the comments
kelly stay strong kelly
foreign